الى عمان واللواء فايز الدويري لواء فايز
يعني السيد
يستبعد امكانيه ان تكون هذه الطائره قد
استهدفت بصاروخ من خلال مشاهدناه من صور
ومعلومات الى حد الان وان كانت شحيحه ومما
لديكم من خبره هل تستبعدون امكانيه
استهدافها بصاروخ
اما خلل فني او تفجير داخلي او استهداف
خارجي
وسافسر في جمله او اكثر لكل حاله
الخلل الفني لا يمكن ان يفقد الطائره عن
شاشه الرادار فورا والطائره فقدت الخلل
الفني لا يمكن ان يقطع الاتصال مع مع قائد
الطائره والاتصال قطع اذا الخلل الفني
خارج الحسابات
ناتي الى الامر الاخر الاسقاط الخارجي
الاسقاط الخارجي هناك حالتين لا ثالث لهما
اما اصابه جسم الطائره والطائره تتحطم او
اصابه جناح الطائره والطائره تسقط وهناك
من تحدث بان الطائره سقطت بجناح واحد ولم
يؤكد ذلك الخبر من مصدر اخر
يبقى الاحتمال الثالث وهو ان يكون بفعل
فاعل اي بتفجير داخلي باستخدام قنبله
موقوته الان
الطائره بعد 26 دقيقه قطع الاتصال اختفت
عن شاشه الرادار على ارتفاع 29 الف قدم
فقدت 29 الف قدم يقودنا الى نوعيه محدده
من الصواريخ وهي الصواريخ متوسطه وبعيده
المدى اي نسقط من الحسابات كل انواع
الصواريخ قصيره المدى الصواريخ بعيده
المدى
ومتوسطه وعاليه نبدا في حسابات سامي اثنين
سام ثلاث سام اربعه وحتى الحديث سام خمسه
الان هذه هذه الصواريخ يجب ان تفجر
الطائره يجب ان لنا صواريخ كبيره الحجم
اذا تتضاعى الفرصه الاسقاط الخارجي مقابل
فرضيه التفجير الداخلي
في حاله تفجير الداخلي
ستكون حسابات دقيقه
بحيث تكون موقع الحشوه
ووزن الحشوه وطريقه توضيع وتوجيه الحشوه
داخل الطائره بحسابات دقيقه يعرفها
المختصين في هذا المجال وبالتالي ستحذف
فجوه في جسم الطائره في مكان ما يؤدي الى
اختلال توازن الطائره وبدع السقوط الذي
شاهدناه انا من خبرتي وهذا جزء من تخصصي
ارجع لا انفي ارجع بصوره كبيره جدا فرضيه
التفجير من الداخل
وقد يكون احتمال اقل
واقعيه وعقلانيه اسقاط من الخارج بصاروخ
اصاب جناح الطائره وليس بدن الطائره لكن
القول الفصل واليقيني في الصندوق الاسود
اذا
بما انه دم العثور على الجثث وغير ذلك
والصندوق الاسود بمكان حريز ومكان امن
الصندوق الاسود لدخيل هذا البيانات
ولكن قبل ذلك لابد من التنويه الى ما ياتي
من اخبار عاجله مصدر سياسي في مجموعه
فاغنر يقول للجزيره كان عائدا عبر موسكو
الى سان بيترسبرج بعد رحله الى افريقيا
اعود مره جديده اليك لواء فايز لواء فايز
تحليل بيانات الصندوق الاسود هل هي عمليه
معقده تحتاج الى وقت طويل
هذا يعتمد على رغبه الان اول شيء ما هي
حاله هذا الصندوق
في كثير من الحالات حتى عندما كانت تسقط
الطائره في البحر حتى يتم الوصول الى
الصندوق واستخراجه من قعر البحر وهذه هي
اجراءات ما قبل بدء التحقيق لكن عنده بدء
التحقيق يعتمد الان كما قلت لك على الحاله
العامه له ومن ثم على تفريغ الاشرطه او
المحتويات او الشرائح التي خزنت عليها
كافه معلومات الرحله وبالتالي الصندوق
الاسود في حال العثور عليه سيغني اذا اذا
نشرت محتوياته سيبين الحقائق بدرجه مطلقه
وسيتبين ما هو سبب السقوط وينتهي الحديث
في بعد الافتراضات لكن انا كانسان مختص في
علم المتفجرات اقول من خلال متابعتي
للجزئيه التي شاهدناها في الفيديو والتي
يوجد بها حلقه مفقوده لم نشاهدها وهي التي
جعلتني
الحلقه المفقوده وما الذي تقصده بذلك ولكن
لابد من التنميه الى الاخبار العاجله مصدر
سياسي في مجموعه
يقول للجزيره لسوء الحظ من المحتمل جدا ان
يكون بريجوجل قد توفي بشكل
ماساوي اذا هذه المعلومات التي ترد الينا
من مصدر سياسيا داخل مجموعه
يؤكد ايضا للجزيره ان لا تخمينات لدى
فاجنر حتى الان ويتم التواصل مع السلطات
التي تدرس الوضع بشكل شامل انتقل من هذا
الخبر العاجل الاخير لواء فايز الدويري لا
تخمينات لدى فاجنر حتى الان يتم التواصل
مع السلطات التي تدرس الوضع بشكل شامل هل
يمكن ان يفسر ذلك وجود طائره ثانيه تقول
الانباء بانها تعود لشركه فاجنر وانها
هبطت
في مطار من المطارات في روسيا
يعني المعلومات حول الطائره الثانيه كانت
معلومات ضبابيه معظمها تناولها مراسل
الجزيره في وكان يتواجد في منطقه القفقاش
يعني قيل بان بريجوجل حذر جدا وبالتالي
فقط كان هناك احتماليه يعني المعلومات عن
الطائره الثانيه مجموعه من المواقع
تناولتها وايضا
محطات تلفزه روسيه تناولتها تفضل اكبر نعم
نعم انا اقول ما تابعته وشاهدته الان يقال
بان بريجوجين كان حذر جدا وبعض الاشارات
اشارت بان المسؤول الوحيد عن حركه
قتل في نفس الحادث اي انه كان معه
وبالتالي هذه يعني اذا اخذنا موضوع الحذر
فقد يكون في العاده كما يعمل كثير من
الزعامات بحركه اكثر من طائره في نفس
الوقت للتمويل عن الطائره التي يوجد بها
وحتى على مستوى المواكب الارضيه في كثير
من الزعماء يتحرك تتحرك اربعه الى خمسه
الى عشر سيارات نفس السياره المظلله ولا
يعرف في اي سياره يتواجد فقد تكون يعني
هذا تحليل قد تكون هذه الطائره الثانيه
كانت هي في مجال التمويل ولكن عندما
وتحركوا بفارق زمني قصير جدا ولكن عندما
سقطت الطائره وتلقطت للطائره الثانيه او
الطيار الثاني هذا الخبر عاد ادراج الرياح
خوفا من ان يكون هناك استهدافا او خوفا من
ان يكون هناك شيء سيء قد يحدث فعاد مسرعا
وهبط هبوطا اضطراريا لتجنب مصير الطائره
التي
اسقطت ولا اقول سقط